what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to eminem um godzilla
featuring juice world this video was
actually suggested to me by one of my
subscribers so if you guys have a video
that you want to see go to my instagram
dm it to me on there um it's just not
pearly things
yeah so that's my instagram so
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel a lot of these videos get
demonetized because of the music so
you know help a girl out if you've
watched more than three of these
i don't i do this for free basically so
okay i'm gonna go
you're a monster i can swallow a bottle
of alcohol a little feel like godzilla
better hit the deck like the cartila my
whole squad's in here walking around the
party across between the zombie
apocalypse
brain healing which is probably the same
reason i wrestle with maniacs in this
[ __ ] i'm passing up considering
[Music]
that was clever
it's kind of weird seeing eminem's voice
coming from a different dude but i like
the song so far
actually this is a five so far okay
[Music]
way to the bank i spray flames it's
cray-cray
it is i i really like the like
oh my god did i just
never ride can i take my place
i look like a villain
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god i love this so far
this is great this is a great song
i'm just the product that's the quickest
total nickname
why is she looking
that's unsanitary oh my god can you
imagine
being like a girl recruited for a music
video and they say
lick this
basketball it's
impossible them off and in the midst of
all this i'm in a mental hospital with a
crystal ball trying to see what i scare
me like this to my wrist but dog versus
whispering
back up against the wall pencil drawn
this is just the song to go ballistic on
you just pull the pistol on the guy with
a missile launcher i'm just a loch ness
the mythological quick to tell a [ __ ]
you off like a fifth of vodka man she's
still licking it what is going on i like
this this song would actually go on my
playlist i'm bopping push the top of the
bottle i'm a monster you get in my way
imma feed you to the monster
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
oh my god that's clever i love it when
people are clever and you admire these
chicks are spazzing out i only get more
handsome and flyer i've got no plans to
retire i'm still the man you admire oh
my god oh my god he's going crazy
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm a player i'm two [ __ ]
stingy for sure won't even lend you an
air ain't even pretending to care but i
tell the [ __ ] i'm married she'll bury a
face of my genital area the original
richard ramirez christian revere cause
my lyrics never sit well so they wanna
give me the chairs like a paraplegic and
it's scary called the hairy carrot guy
is so clever so freaking clever i can't
even
damn that's clever
because every time i'm digging harry
carrie and miriam [ __ ]
dictionary on them swearing up and down
they can spit this shit's hilarious it's
time to put these [ __ ]
it's time to put these [ __ ] in the
obituary okay that
why
what did i do
what the staring problem get the shaft
like a steering column
drink it happy pacquiao
half of the bad meats evil that means
take a backseat take it back to fat
beats with a maxi single look at my rap
sheet what attracts these people is my
gangster [ __ ] like a patchy with a
catchy jiggle snack chips you barely got
a half eaten cheeto
[Music]
oh what the [ __ ]
mike m is that you
mike tyson is in this i did not see that
coming i mean please man i'm sorry
please forgive me
fill him with the venom and eliminate
him other words i'm enemies
[Music]
the epitome of the spirit when i'm in
the vicinity [ __ ] you better be
dead to me 100 of you is a fifth of a
percent of me i'm about to [ __ ]
finish you [ __ ] i'm infertile you want
to battle i'm available i'm blowing up
like an inflatable unbeatable i'm
unavoidable i'm uninvitable i'm on the
toilet i got a trailer for the money and
i'm painful i'm not afraid to pull them
i've no idea what he just said that was
a lot
stop stop look what i'm planning
now they kill him i hope everybody
having a good day
they're having so many left turns this
is oh this is going to be sad because he
died didn't he
hope everybody accomplished something
significant
you can even even if you didn't
accomplish anything significant don't be
discouraged just aim to accomplish
something significant tomorrow and the
next day
[Music]
um
if anybody's going through anything
i hope and i pray that you people loved
juice world like
my ex-boyfriend loved juice world and
that's like the one celebrity he said
he'd care about meeting
get through it and just know that you do
have the strength to get through
whatever the [ __ ] you're going through
no matter what it is
song i'm gonna give a five i oh shoot
wrong way i loved it that song was great
actually that's one of the few fives
i've given on this channel i do one to
five scale
let me know guys in the comments what
you think don't forget to subscribe to
the channel especially subscribe because
again i do these basically for free so
if you're not subscribed we got beef
and i'll talk to you guys next time